[Applaudissements]
ça c'est pour planter l'ambiance
l'ambiance d'un club qui raflent tous
les titres de champion de la martinique
depuis 21 ans
mais pour ça petit retour en arrière
le club franciscain avait décidé de
jouer la finale en famille quand c'est
un autre franciscaine fabrice est dit
que zain qui se retrouvait face à denis
dans six coeurs c'était en 1997
les franciscains avait déjà commencé
leur hold up du tennis de table
régionale
vingt ans plus tard rien n'a changé
c'est une famille où on françois donc on
est là depuis 77 les faire de ces cartes
a prévenu le petit jeune des dicos sac
après on a rattrapé cru ou là des titres
qu'ils évoluent au fond soit comme
anthony roux de se rencontrer avec les
jeunes et a toujours troisièmes mi-temps
et puis les jeunes me disent qu'ils ont
besoin d'un vieux donc un enjeu de cette
année là allez beaucoup de belles jeunes
femmes qu'il faut que l'équipe est
encore plus belle et la blessure pour
murs et voilà tout est dit la famille
des verts s'est agrandie et le palmarès
aussi et à l'entraînement on ne
plaisante pas
désormais c'est plutôt christian qui
anime les troupes et ne lui dites
surtout pas que vous savez jouer au ping
pong ça c'est pour l'aspect loisir le
tennis de table est un sport avec son
lot de technicité et pour être un bon
geste accompli
mieux vaut être en forme des réflexes un
peu et aussi avoir beaucoup de
concentration parce que il faut analyser
la balle qui arrive parce que selon le
geste
la balle arrive avec un certain échec et
il faut à ce moment là pour orienter la
raquette en fonction donc il va couper
qu'il faut ouvrir une balise t il faut
fermer là je ferme et sociale en
maintenant si on passe en coupe et on
pousse la balle on pousse la balle
l'enquêté ouverte par la balle quand ils
se retrouvent à l'entraînement deux fois
par semaine il enchaîne les matches
l'ancienne génération affronter la
nouvelle les plus forts forme les
derniers arrivés et petit à petit le
niveau augmente encore rares dans la
discipline ces dames aussi sont de la
partie
on joue pas beaucoup
moi je joue avec les
avec les seniors à défaut parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on pense c'est
beaucoup de physique surtout pour les
gens et c'est compliqué parce qu'il ya
vraiment des gestes à avoir pour bien
jouer et il faut croire que cela marche
puisque hormis les titres individuels le
club franciscain pants un titre de
champion antiglio par équipes dans les
deux derniers consécutifs 2017 2018 les
autres années les verts s'étaient
inclinés en finale
à